[Musique]
legueulle
on aimera et voilà que le meriva nous de
quoi lui dans une série appelée you full
house live au delà si le port
m
maintenant le saut
ce qui
je ne
oh
[Musique]
moi
a game on a donc
il
ceux qui aiment emea
gervais en main
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
analyse
les trouver
le plan
et après
ce pas
c'est un tout le plein
entier
il
dans le sun
un pouvoir
je sais qu'ils me mo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec moi
et là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette bombe atomique
beaucoup de cette mode est exceptionnel
c'est quoi ce qui flatte sa forêt au
tien déniera est lé seul adore elle a un
caractère de ouf
non mais franchement sans éclat ni
comment ça va ma chérie tu es trop belle
s'échoue merci c'est quoi cette bombe
atomique la norme et là tu sais que je
t'aime très fort vraiment est formidable
elle cartonne à chaque fois une voix
incroyable vraiment un caractère de ouf
et on te kiffe
j'adore aussi coup c'est ta faim car
encore plus plongeant qu'avant oui il
est très plongeant bret a fait part et
splash l'album une première album 300000
exemplaires vendus là on dit explique
éric explicite express ethias cet album
sortira le 20 octobre prochain et il y
aura pour la première fois des titres en
français et même une reprise du titre
vole de céline dion que je kiffe aussi
et enfin le titre j'aime bien ces lignes
aux sims et un autre délire et ma chérie
je voulais dire il faut que tu reviennes
me voir après parce que tu vas venir
nous voir là bientôt quand tu veux t'en
parler eh ben tu viens quand tu me aussi
tu sais qu'on t'aime et franchement tu
as un talent exceptionnel l'album de
marine at on vraiment le change rien
merci de sueur et merci d'avoir été là
là c'est marie là il adore que la dorna
ah oui
[Applaudissements]